hey guys what we're going to see now is
a little bit of switching between me and
katie we share three languages more than
three languages and we want to just show
you how it is to switch from one
language to the other it's just
something for the fun of it we hope
you're going to like it
okay katie so what we're going to do now
like for 30 seconds one minute two
minutes i don't know uh we're just gonna
have a conversation where we have to
switch and the only rule is that you
have to reply in a language that is
different from the language i'm
currently speaking in right
hello
why you decided to go to milan
yes
yes
i like
i like milan i didn't like it at first
in fact i was only supposed to come on
holiday
um
but then after a while i really like the
lifestyle because it feels quite small
even though it's a big city
i like it but i wouldn't go back to live
because
i love languages and
they don't speak so it's it's harder to
speak foreign languages in sheffield not
impossible
for example
[Music]
[Music]
probably just italian on a day-to-day
basis in fact my languages are a little
bit rusty at the moment
so this was a demonstration how to
switch it was
slightly challenging now yeah
not to get confused but i you get the
idea this is no magic it's really easy
to change if it's a skill you develop so
it's something that you can easily
develop it's difficult to say something
different in in a single conversation
but i believe you can manage if you have
three different people and you stick to
one conversation at a time you know
don't constantly switch i think it's
manageable right yeah yeah the last
thing i wanted to say is that everything
is possible you see everything is
possible if you want it you just have to
put in some work some discipline and you
can accomplish the impossible thank you
very much
and love from milan
[Music]
you